there were 16 513 uncompany miners right
now in this country
stephen miller former senior advisor to
the president united states speech
writing architect
of a lot of the immigration policy joins
us now stephen did you let little kids
die
what joe biden said at that press
conference is a detestable lie
it's not just a smear against president
trump
it's a smear against the patriotic
border agents
who save the lives who rescue who rescue
unaccompanied minors
and get them safely back home that was
our policy
if you came here as say a 15 year old
from honduras
and border patrol apprehended you they
would then process you
put you on a chartered flight paid for
by the u.s
government send you back to your home
country meet up with social services in
honduras
work with our state department to get
you back with your
own family joe biden is separating these
families
stranding them in the united states and
sending the message not just to central
america brian
but to the whole world that if you split
off
your family if you send someone here 17
or younger
alone they will stay here for life
stephen what's
so amazing is i'm not i'm not sure he
knows his own policy
he was asked in the scenario would you
send that child home
if their mom sent him here because
america was open he goes no if their mom
was there i'd fly him home
that's not the policy you come here you
get to stay
he's got to tell jen saki that they show
up with a note in their pocket they get
to stay
and since we're in stephen are you
allowed just to keep the press
out of these facilities let them into
one that looks sanitized
is that allowed no so a couple things
there
number one his administration in
writing terminated the reunification
policy we had in place
to send unaccompanied minors back to
their home countries
wherever they may come from and that's
why last year we had record low
numbers of unaccompanied minors in
custody because we weren't releasing
them
he terminated that policy in writing
that's not in dispute
i guess he doesn't know or his staff is
lying to him so that he then can mislead
the country
as for access to facilities his answer
that he'll give people access once his
mystical plan is in place
this plan that no one's ever heard of
that no one knows what's in it no one
knows what it's going to do
isn't transparency it's a cover-up
you're saying
unless and until i am ready you won't
get to see what's going on
i cannot believe the media would go
along with that i know and i can't
believe
you said you're going to be transparent
you're going to let us into the facility
he goes yeah i just don't know when
why is that allowed real quick he says
that you guys took down all the
facilities
that allowed you to to store these
people there and give them the
accommodations they deserved did you
guys take down the infrastructure
no far from it we built a safe orderly
humane infrastructure
to accomplish the end goal of border
security
which is orderly return and removal to
the place you come from
we didn't need surge facilities to hold
tens
hundreds of thousands of people with the
way that we're going
because we had a process for returning
them be it to mexico central america or
elsewhere
he dismantled that process invited the
surge
and now he has nowhere to put them he
wants to talk about his 1.9 trillion
dollars he wants to talk about 1400
in everyone's pocket but those are not
the issues the issues are the
immigration story and also
voter hr one and what's happening in a
lot of states is they're tightening up
their rules when it comes to
signature verification and just uh
identification
maybe a picture id that's what's
happening in georgia it was chronicled
and listed by some
as racist here is the newest senator
senator warnock
talking about what's happening in
georgia where they're going to give you
four days now for early voting and ask
for a reason when it comes to absentee
voting
and ask for id listen to what senator
warnock says
they are using the lie about voter fraud
as a pretext for voter suppression
this is jim crow redux in new clothes
there is no reason for this what we saw
was
black voters all across the country
standing up
other voters of color young people women
students
and they made a difference in the
election
is this jim crow redux and is hr1
going to purify the system you know it's
so insulting
to every citizen of this country to say
that it's a civil rights violation to
ask somebody for an id to vote
you need an id in this country to rent a
car to cash a check
depending on your age to buy liquor for
the sacred franchise
the idea that we cannot have a simple
identity confirmation request
by the way that's even more important
now that biden's letting in
hundreds of thousands of people unvetted
unchecked
unauthorized how do we make sure they're
not going to be voting in our next
election
you do that with voter id it's
suspicious
that democrats suddenly decided that
voter id
violates civil rights i think it's
because they want people who aren't
citizens voting in our elections
those right-wing states uh called
california virginia and nevada
all require a photo id and social
security number i want you to hear what
governor kemp just said
on this channel about that accusation
that it's un-american
and jim crow redux listen he obviously
doesn't realize what's in the final
version of the georgia bill he's
probably been reading
things on twitter from people that are
fundraising saying that we're
restricting or limiting in georgia and
that's not the case we're securing the
vote
i think most people want that whether
they're democrat
republican or somewhere in between
everybody wants to have confidence in
the election
steve this is very important because
states should be the the state's rights
thing is in the constitution
if you're going to federalize elections
that's that's not going to stand up to a
constitutional test but if hr 1 passes
that's exactly what will happen and
that's what they're debating on the
senate floor today final thought
this is not a partisan issue every
citizen has the right
to have their franchise protected to
make sure their vote isn't canceled out
by someone who's not authorized to vote
voter id is just plain old-fashioned
common sense
and i like most americans i'm tired of
the bogus racism allegations
that are used to block basic reforms to
protect
voter integrity and signature
verification
protects your vote too same thing in
colorado they have signature
verification they throw out of one out
of every 112
ballots i'm pretty sure that's bright
blue uh stephen miller i think your
points taken i can tell you're fired up
and
even though it ended at two o'clock you
had to stay calm until
seven and i appreciate the composure
brian all right okay appreciate it
stephen miller thank you very much